[Musique]
le directeur du centre hospitalier
universitaire de martinique et dans ce
cas dit bonjour jamais garrel
bonjour en poste depuis le 1er août un
premier tour de force obtenu depuis
votre arrivée savoir afficher une unité
face avec toute la communauté
hospitalière
face à une ministre le passage en
l'occurrence agnès buzyn c'était la
première étape c'était une des premières
étapes et encore beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à faire mais effectivement malgré
des points de vue différents
l'ensemble des professionnels ont réussi
à montrer un visage uni face à la
ministre et je suis très fier d'eux est
vraiment très content qu'on ait pu
montrer ce visage la première étape
indispensable dans la crédibilité que
vous recherchez face au gouvernement
face aux partenaires financiers aux
créanciers aux banques
exactement on doit rassurer nos
partenaires on peut pas s'en sortir seul
actuellement serait une entreprise
privée on serait en situation de dépôt
de bilan
donc va falloir que on rassure nos
partenaires qu'on montre que quand la
situation exige on sait être unie et je
fais je suis sûr qu'on peut continuer à
être unis dans cette difficulté extrême
qu'est la situation du chu actuellement
alors emmanuel macron annoncé une
enveloppe de 45 millions d'euros
c'est une vraie bulle d'oxygène pour
vous ou juste une goutte d'eau pour
faire face face à l'ampleur de la
situation
disons que c'est un peu l'intermédiaire
entre les deux ça va nous permettre
d'avoir une bouffée d'oxygène mais ça va
pas nous en remettre totalement à flot
il va falloir que très vite derrière on
arrive à faire des gains importants
améliorer la prise en charge du patient
a relancé un petit peu l'activité pour
pour s'en sortir financièrement et pas
qu'on se retrouve dans englué dans les
difficultés qu'on connaît actuellement
la dette cumulée de l'établissement
était de 800 millions d'euros au départ
des trois inspecteurs de l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales venus en
mission chez nous il ya un pendant six
mois il ya eu un gel des dettes sociales
disons qu'il ya certaines certaines
cotisations qu'on ne paye plus
actuellement pour pouvoir mieux payer
nos fournisseurs notamment les
fournisseurs du bassin martiniquais
cette dette
c'est un boulet que le chu va devoir
traîniez et qui vous paralyse
alors non parce que d'avoir cette dette
est une ya plus des deux tiers qui ont
été effacées par par l'état qui chaque
année apporté 100 millions d'euros en
liquidités ce qui nous paralyse
actuellement c'est un très gros déficit
de trésorerie d'un peu près 100 millions
qui nous oblige à payer nos fournisseurs
a quasiment un an et payer les
fournisseurs un grand retard ma ça
paralyse beaucoup de nos fournisseurs
l'urgence au quotidien déjà la gare elle
c'est quoi c'est la gestion jour au jour
le jour des services des salariés des
services dont on annonce la fermeture
puis pour lesquels on trouve une
demi-mesure on parle par exemple du
service hématologie
disons que on a très éloigné de la
métropole est un des points clés pour
nous et qui est difficile c'est
l'attractivité médicale on a une offre
totale complète et on est le seul
hôpital de la martinique avoir une offre
complète en hémato en cancer ou en or
tôt en tout et il faut avoir des
médecins dans chacune de ces spécialités
s'est pas forcément facile de faire
venir des médecins ici avec un petit
bassin de population une activité qui
n'est pas très forte et brice conditions
de travail à cause de quoi c'est parce
qu'on sait que cet établissement va mal
non c'est multifactoriel en fait ces
requins effectivement on a des
conditions de travail qui sont
difficiles les conditions de prise en
charge que l'on voudrait pas avoir à
certains endroits qui sont très très
bien mais d'autres qui sont pas
acceptables mais après ça l'autre chose
c'est que vous avez un chu dans un
bassin de 400000 personnes pour avoir
dans un chu ce que les médecins
recherchez une activité dite de retour
de soins complexes et pour avoir cette
activité de recours faut plutôt avoir un
bassin de population de 1 à 2 voire 3
millions d'habitants et
et du coup ça fait que le dynamisme des
équipes n'est pas favorable à
l'attractivité des médecins c'est pour
ça qu'on essaye toujours enfin ce que
dit emmanuel macron si ce qu il fallait
qu on coopère avec avec la guadeloupe
pour passer déjà un bassin de population
de 800 mille huit cent mille personnes
voir avec la guyane voir avec le les
îles anglophones
cette nécessité de travailler ensemble
entre fort-de-france et pointe-à-pitre
il ya quand même des freins il ya ce
billet d'avion qui scandaleusement trop
élevé entre pointe à pitre et fort de
france il ya la nécessité de travailler
de façon pluridisciplinaire ce sont des
frais qui peuvent être surmontées assez
rapidement et elle billets d'avion il
reste toujours moins cher que celui
d'aller en france ou à miami en
métropole ou à miami
en revanche je pense qu'il ya ce qu'il
faut trouver c'est la volonté de
coopérer et ce qu'on voit c'est que
cette volonté
elle a déjà eu lieu dans deux
disciplines par exemple en neurologie
les greffes se font en guadeloupe et en
cardiologie tout âge est ce compliqué se
font en martinique
oui et on voit qu'on a su le faire sur
deux spécialités nous d'arriver à le
faire sur les autres ouais parce que il
ya quand même cet épisode du cyclotron
oui à cet épisode du cyclotron
effectivement le wall oups est équipé
d'un cyclotron et manger j'ai été le
voir avec mes équipes
il n'est pas capable de nous livrer il
n'est pas assez puissant ce qui est fort
dommage parce que du coup on est deux à
avoir des cyclotrons qui sont dès qu'ils
sont l'instruction en avance à eux au
niveau de la guadeloupe oui sont en
avance après ça nous on séance mais au
travail je pense que dans deux ans il
sera rattrapé
ouais alors justement une question très
précise après des propos d' emmanuel
macron jeudi dernier est-ce que
certainement imaginer que le cyclotron
pour la martinique c'est mort
définitivement qu'est-ce qu'on répondra
ce matin à barres ce serait une
catastrophe parce que le cyclotron
guadeloupe n'est pas capable de nous
livrer donc ça veut dire qu'on
continuerait les évacuations sanitaires
simplement pour une gamma caméra ou un
pet scan donc non ce n'est pas le cas au
contraire nous on est en train de
travailler sur le prochain projet n'est
pas mort bon nom plein dessus bon et
comment faire maintenant pour éviter
qu'on se retrouve avec
une même femme proposée à 2 aux moules
inverse pour ne pas ne pas choquer les
féministes pour éviter des couacs par
exemple l'annnonce de service sur tel ou
tel territoire et puis finalement qui
devra discuter qui devra parler ce sont
les directeurs du chu sont solides et
les directeurs des ars venir du
ministère comment ça peut se passer une
sorte d'harmonisation entre les deux
territoires voir avec la guyane
moi ce que je pense qu'elle plus
important c'est qu'on bâtisse un lien de
confiance entre les équipes médicales du
chu de la guadeloupe et du chu de
lamartine c'est le médical d'abord qui
doit décider
bah ce qu'on voit c'est que quand ils
ont confiance l'un en l'autre ils ont
réussi à se mettre d'accord sur la
cardiologie
c'est vraiment les équipes médicales qui
se connaissaient et qui ont bâti un
système qui est très performant et qui
permet d'attirer les médecins on a
d'excellents cardiologue du cher qu'à
cher cardiaque et cher thoracique on a
une super équipe et qui en plus c'est
bien articulé avec la guadeloupe
à nous de la faire ça ensemble je suis
j'espère pouvoir monter en avait charcot
selon le directeur de la guadeloupe je
connais bien
puis je pense que vous avez raison nous
y aider est ce que une réponse n'a
jamais garrel se seraient pas tout
simplement la création de grands chu
antilles l'idée a déjà été évoquée
l'idée effectivement a été évoqué c'est
pas du tout au goût du jour un nous on
se bat tous les jours pour améliorer les
conditions de prise en charge des
patients prince ainsi c'est pas le
changement de structure administrative
qui fera quelque chose alors jamais
garenne on le rappelle vous êtes arrivé
ici à fort de france le 1er août
vous avez obtenu cette unité en tout cas
de façade avec les centrales syndicales
c'est des syndicats qui qui vous
observent est ce qu'on doit attendre une
sorte de 2 de la fin de cette période
d'observation avec le nouveau venu
oubliez vous avez l'impression que tout
le monde peut regarder dans la même
direction avec les partenaires sociaux
alors je pense que pas courir à damas
toujours on verra peut-être même dans la
même direction n'en verra pas les mêmes
choses donc il y aura toujours des
discussions animées faut voir en plus
que est-ce qu'on va continuer à
ressasser pendant encore de longs mois
de lons de longues années
que s'il ya une situation de faillite
pour le chu a baissé à cause de la
fusion oui et certains syndicats qui en
parlent tout le temps et qui en
parleront et je pense que il faut
entendre ce qu'ils nous disent
effectivement il ya il ya eu suite à la
fusion des dégradations de conditions de
travail sur plusieurs de nos sites
alors est-ce que c'était dû à la fusion
hausse est due aussi à ceux à des
moments où on fait la pression
financière c'est aux nomes moment
augmenté dans l'ensemble des hôpitaux
français aussi bien en métropole qu'en
martinique ou en guadeloupe et donc le
ils ont l'impression que ça vient de la
fusion est ce que ça vient de la fusion
est ce que ça vient cette pression
financière qui s'est aggravée par tous
je ne sais pas je pense que oui
continuons à en parler il continue à en
parler c'est pas grave moi je
dialoguerait toujours avec eux dans le
respect et des échéances importantes
pour eux le 6 décembre avec les
élections professionnelles je pense que
le dialogue continuera d'être très
intense qu'elle n'importe lequel
plusieurs gens là pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est de reprendre tous les dossiers
étage par étage service par service pour
savoir quelles sont quels sont les
pertinence de certains choix par exemple
transfert de tels services par exemple
de mango bull c'est à pierre
zobda-quitman nous et c'est revoir la
capacité d'accueil de des malades par
exemple certains sites
le plus important c'est d'améliorer la
prise en charge des patients donc ça
nécessite parfois des transferts de
revoir effectivement d'augmenter délit à
certains endroits fin notre capacité de
prise en charge de la diminuer à
d'autres d'augmenter l'équipe à un
endroit de la diminuer à d'autres mais
notre premier souci c'est d'améliorer la
qualité des soins sur la martinique
merci merci benjamin car elle d'avoir
été ce matin avec nom rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur du chu de martinique
et que vous êtes en poste depuis le 1er
août de cette année bonne année bonne
journée